years c-span
the cable industry's gift to america
now a hearing on threats to u.s national
security today the senate armed services
committee heard from cia director george
tenet and the director of the defense
intelligence agency lieutenant general
patrick hughes on the issue the two-hour
hearing is chaired by virginia senator
john warner
let's see
the
committee on the armed services will
come to order
we welcome uh the director of the
central intelligence agents the director
of the defense intelligence agents we
thank both of you
for joining us in long tradition this
committee
initiates its annual
work under the authorization bill with a
worldwide survey from our intelligence
i've always viewed intelligence as a
force multiplier
for a relatively small investment
america
can
obtain that knowledge
which
best enables the planners
to structure the size of the forces
to equip the forces
and to project in the out years the
research and development that is needed
to meet the emerging threat
this committee has established a
subcommittee in recognition of the
seriousness
as a consequence of the
spread of
weapons of mass destruction
the ever-increasing tempo of terrorism
the diversification of the sources
and the reasons for which that terrorism
is brought to bear
on our country
so i'm going to ask that my statement be
placed in the record because i'm quite
anxious to proceed to receive the
testimony of our two witnesses
11.
mr chairman thank you and i want to join
you in welcoming both of our witnesses
this morning and
their testimony on current and future
worldwide threats
sets the stage for the hearing tomorrow
with secretary cohen and general shelton
and the other hearings which you've
scheduled mr chairman for this committee
that we're going to be holding in the
coming weeks
the advanced testimony of our witnesses
this morning provides a very sobering
view of the future particularly the
threat of weapons of mass destruction
and terrorism
and the potential of terrorist use of
chemical biological and radiological
weapons
and it is important for us to fully
understand
the most likely threats to our deployed
military forces into our homeland
it's important for us to understand
whether
it is likely very likely or what the
elem what the degree of likelihood is
that a rogue state or a terrorist group
would attack the united states with a
weapon of mass destruction smuggled
across our borders
and compare that to the other potential
threats that we face for instance the
missile threat
it is important for us to hear from our
witnesses uh on the situation in the
balkans
including bosnia kosovo macedonia and
albania
both our witnesses in their prepared
testimony have indicated a real concern
about the increasing ability as director
tenet says
of small actors to have a large impact
on u.s interests
and i very much share these concerns
although i've long supported for
instance our military involvement in
bosnia for a number of years
i've been urging the continuing
reduction of u.s combat forces in bosnia
and their replacement
by a combination of military and
paramilitary forces primarily from
europe
and we should hear from our witnesses
and we'll hear from our witnesses today
relative to the
situations that we face in bosnia and
kosovo
and other places in the balkans and
around the world but
at least i want to
add one
comment here of my own and that is that
i applaud the european initiative
in seeking to achieve and implement a
peace settlement in kosovo
and given the threats that we're going
to hear about that we face around the
world and our commitments
that we've made around the world it's
important for
the europeans to take the lead more
often in their own backyard
so we are going to be facing a number of
decisions in the next few weeks relative
to possible nato air strikes
to trying to address some of the threats
which we're going to hear about this
morning
but in the meantime
i do want to express my own
very strong support for the europeans
taking the lead in nato
in addressing some of those threats
in the balkan countries and particularly
in kosovo
and i look forward to the testimony of
our witnesses on the broad range of
threats and agree with you mr chairman
that
the intelligence that they help us to
gather and to
organize for the consideration of our
policy makers is critically important to
the development of useful and effective
policies
thank you very much senator levin i i
too join in
recognizing
at long last the
nato nations and indeed i think through
strong leadership from the united states
are now recognizing the need to deal
with the problems in kosovo i have
spoken out for many months on this
subject consistently indicating that in
my judgment airstrikes alone would not
secure that country
secure it in such a way that it does not
leak over into the situation in bosnia
this country has an enormous investment
together with our allies and what we've
been able to achieve although quite
modest in my judgment what we've been
able to achieve to bring about the
cessation of hostilities
and the economic
restructuring and rebuilding of bosnia
but the instability in kosova could
bring that creeping progress to a halt
and indeed make it far more difficult
and put at risk our own troops in bosnia
and it's for that reason that i've sort
of spoken out in the senate for the last
four months indicating
that a ground force element is essential
in kosova in the region of pristina
and that a
segment of that force should consist of
u.s
personnel primarily in the intelligence
in the communication to lend support to
the commander-in-chief of all nato
forces and american general general
clark so that's my views on that senator
i hope than do course that you can share
those views
senator thurman do you have a word to
welcome our thank you very much mr
chairman i ask unanimous consent to open
a statement by me
father your statement for the record
thank you very much senator rob do you
and uh senator yes i have some questions
for the witnesses and you can
i can need to be answered for the record
they certainly can we recognize you have
to open the senate at 10 o'clock that's
right thank you senator rob uh thank you
mr chairman and uh as you do uh we both
have a funeral to attend later today it
had been my hope to come back
and uh particularly in the closed
section closed session to ask some
questions i hope that we might be able
to submit the questions for the record
that will be done the circumstances i
share your concern and views with
respect to uh the severity of this
particular situation and have uh been
urging uh a more assertive rule for a
similar period of time and i thank you
for your
both position leadership on this and i
look forward to hearing from
both director tenant and general hughes
thank you the record will remain open
for the submission of questions
for the balance of the 24-hour period
after this hearing senator sessions
thank you mr chairman uh i i would just
wait for my time to question would uh
move on to the our guests
the senate has been under sort of an
irregular schedule for some time and
that
i think speaks to the absence of a
number of our colleagues
we scheduled this hearing weeks ago
recognizing the importance in order to
keep the work of the senate
going forward senator
lott has urged committee chairman to set
these hearings
and therefore we set this one not
recognizing that on this day normally a
very active day in the senate a number
of members are now returning
to the city
so with that we'll proceed
senator i think a
brief opening statement by both of you
relative to kosovo
would be a wise place to begin so
perhaps you can start with that
thank you mr chairman i will i will
start with kosovo and then i will double
back to the
and we'll need to have you draw that
microphone up somewhat more correct
okay
with regard to the balkans mr chairman
and thank you for having us both general
hughes and i believe this is a very
important session it's one of our rare
opportunities to inform the committee
and the american public in open about
the threats the country faces and we
take this responsibility very seriously
so thank you on behalf of both of us for
having us with regard to kosovo mr mr
chairman i i want to go through some
things in a little bit of history and
tell you where i think we are today
with regard to kosovo and the balkans
you are correct it is the most acute
problem
the kosovo liberation army will emerge
from the winter better trained better
equipped and better led than last year
with neither belgrade nor the kosovar
albanians winning willing to compromise
at this point spring will bring harder
fighting and heavier casualties unless
the international community succeeds in
imposing a political settlement
the fragility of any political solution
is likely to generate pressure for the
international community to deploy ground
forces to enforce implementation and to
deter new fighting
kosovo as you know mr chairman of
province of serbia has long been a
flashpoint between the serbian and
albanian communities in what is now the
federal republic of yugoslavia for serbs
kosovo is the birthplace of the serbian
nation and the location of many of the
country's most famous and revered
religious and historical sites
the source of tension is that over time
serb migration from the economically
depressed province combined with a high
birth rate among ethnic albanian
community has resulted in the serbs
becoming a minority they now account for
less than 10 percent of the population
of 2 million
despite these demographic pressures
tensions between the two communities
were contained through the 70s and 80s
during this period kosovo's albanian
majority enjoyed substantial autonomy
and had representation in the main
federal yugoslav bodies
kosovo also had its own constitution
provincial assembly interior ministry
and wide administrative authority
this all changed in 1989 when slobodan
milosevic looking for an emotional and
patriotic issue
issued a rally public support behind his
bid for power
posed as the defender of serve interests
in kosovo he abrogated kosovo's autonomy
on the wildly exaggerated crowns that
the shrinking serb population was being
discriminated against by the albanian
majority
in place of autonomy milosevic imposed
his version of apartheid
shutting down ethnic albanian schools
and local administrative bodies and
forcing ethnic albanians out of
government jobs and state-run businesses
ethnic albanian leaders initially
responded to this repression by
organizing non-violent resistance and
seeking to reach a compromise with
belgrade
these efforts however only resulted in
more repression
by 1996 a loosely organized insurgency
the kosovo liberation army had emerged
dedicated to overthrowing belgrade's
rule by force
the kla grew quickly and was able last
spring to mount low-level attacks
against serb police forces and expand
its presence throughout the province
even exercising effective control over
some areas in central kosovo
alarmed by the growing threat posed by
the kla
belgrade launched a major
counter-insurgency operation that lasted
until late october
serb security forces succeeded in
pushing the kla out of many areas but
they were unable to inflict a mortal
wound
the kla suffered relatively light
casualties and its command structure
remained largely intact
the albanian civil civilian population
was not so fortunate
bearing the brunt of the cert of the
serbs scorched earth campaign
the agreements belgrade signed last
october stem the fighting only
temporarily
the kla used the ceasefire and the
presence of international verifiers to
reoccupy all the territory it lost last
year
and it has kept up a continuous series
of small scale attacks against serb
security forces
belgrade for its part has failed to
comply with many of the provisions of
the october agreements including those
pertaining to troop withdrawals
maintaining considerably more police in
kosovo than permitted under the
agreements reached with nato
the large presence of the so-called
special police the most brutal of the
serb forces in kosovo has served as a
lightning rod for kl8 attacks
mr chairman we believe that we are on
the verge of a dramatic deterioration of
the kosovo crisis
as the limitations of winter weather
pass the cease fire negotiated last
october is near collapse
the number of attacks by both sides is
increasing as are the casualties
both sides are now preparing for much
heavier fighting in the spring
the kla has used the ceasefire to
improve its training and command and
control as well as to acquire more and
better weapons
as a result the kla is a more formidable
force than the serbs faced last summer
we estimate that there are several
thousand kla regulars augmented by
thousands more irregulars or home guards
moreover funds pouring into the kla
coffers from the albanian diaspora have
increased sharply following the massacre
at raychak
we assess that if the fighting escalates
in the spring as we expect it will be
bloodier than last year's
belgrade will seek to crush the kla once
and for all while the insurgents will
have the capability to inflict heavier
casualties on serb forces
both sides will likely step up attacks
on civilians there is already evidence
that the kla may be retaliating for the
slaying of the albanian civilians at the
hands of serb security forces by
attacking serb civilians
the recent attacks that can serve bars
and restaurants in pristina and patch
could be the beginning of a pattern of
tit for tat retaliation that will grow
more severe as fighting intensifies
heavier fighting will also result in
another humanitarian crisis
possibly greater in scale than last
year's which created 250 000 refugees
and internally displaced persons along
with hundreds of buildings destroyed
and homes mr chairman that is the
picture of kosovo's i would paint it a
little history but it's important to
understand how this has evolved
generally
sir i'd like to associate myself with uh
the director's comments i think they're
correct and describe the situation there
the bottom line is that if the warring
parties are not in some way separated
and controlled
we all should expect
increased conflict in the coming spring
and summer months
and continued
strife
throughout the region of the balkans it
could indeed broaden out of the current
crisis environment in kosovo
into the adjoining areas of montenegro
more crisis and more conflict in albania
and the potential for a similar kind of
events in macedonia
so it's indeed a true crisis situation
one that needs attention thank you i
think we'll ask a question or two among
our members on this before we go to the
rest of briefings so i'll just take say
three minutes and then each member
likewise
we have a number of u.s citizens
involved in kosovo now
they're in the k-dom units which i and
other members of this committee have
visited
they've been the monitors of the
situation over there for some number of
months
you have the osc group coming in you
have the ngos
and the significant number of americans
in each of these units
two questions i have i think we have an
obligation to protect those people
particularly if we have to institute
airstrikes
as i said earlier it's my judgment that
only a ground force could
hopefully provide a deterrence to
further conflict
between the kla and other albanian
groups
and the
resident
serbian forces
also i feel that the instability in
kosova could begin to destabilize to the
detriment of the
accomplishments we've had thus far in
the bosnia region and put our troops at
greater risk
i appreciate your comments to both of
those questions mr tennant or do you
want to lead off general
well first i think that you're correct
that
we we have a general policy to protect
human life and to protect certainly the
life of american citizens
and in the balkans
protecting life is quite often a
function of some kind of security
presence or force structure to assist in
the preservation of civil control and
to prevent acts of violence
whether or not a ground force should be
put in place to do that and uh
in the context it appreciates a
political decision political decision
not in within your scope but just from
an analyst and a military person of
great distinction
yes from an analyst standpoint sir
i would say that there needs to be some
kind of a security force in kosovo in
order to stabilize the situation and
protect human life
mr chairman i agree with general hughes
i would only say and it is a policy
issue i think a political settlement is
an indispensable prerequisite before a
ground force is put in
we have to have terms of an agreement
so that the ground force understands
what its mission is very very clearly we
have two warring parties who still have
an enormous amount of capability but i
think it is analytically our judgment is
it would be an indispensable component
in trying to bring some solution here
understood
senator levin
well he said bring a solution you you
in the first part of your sentence said
after there is a
solution or a partial source yes is that
correct
um
you made reference to the balance of
forces there could you be a little more
precise in terms of uh the balance of
power between serb forces and the kla
forces this spring
what do you expect what happened well
the serb forces of course are
it depends on how you measure them but
the serb forces resident in kosovo
are limited to
a specific number and a specific
quantity and type under the current
agreements and force with regard to the
presence of a serb vijay
that's the the army or the military of
serbia the police forces are somewhat
more robust
together the combined serb forces of
army and police represent a much larger
military capability with much heavy
heavy much more heavy weaponry
than that possessed by the uck or the
other smaller groups
of opposing forces
who represent the albanian kosovars
and uh
i believe that
i can't characterize it in numbers but
let's just say that the serbs have a
much more significant military
capability than the albanian opponents
on a relative basis would you say that
relatively the albanians are stronger
this year than they were last year yes
yes
they're in a relatively
improved position militarily is that
correct
the uh you made reference to the uh
massacre
where 38 albanians were
massacred last month and ambassador
walker
viewed the bodies of those
who were slain and he blamed the serbian
security forces for the massacre
he said
that
some of the victims had been executed
gang land style some had their eyes
gouged out there have been reports
that ambassador walker may have
intercepted radio communications that
established that the serbian forces were
responsible for the massacre
can you tell us anything about such uh
radio intercepts do we have any
independent evidence as to which
particular unit might have been
responsible senator i'd be happy to talk
about this in closed session i'd rather
not talk about it
um last question then for open session
this has to do with the
question of
public
um
opinion inside of serbia
senator reid and i were in belgrade in
january of 1997 and
there was a large group of people
demonstrating at that time
against milosevic and for a more
democratic form of government
we have not seen
much evidence of public demonstrations
recently
can you tell us is there organized
democratic opposition in belgrade
uh and if not how has milosevic
succeeded in stifling that opposition
well what he's done recently as you know
senator is consolidate his control over
the government he dismissed the chief of
the general staff he dismissed the
intelligence chief he's put people
around him who are more akin to his own
views
nevertheless i don't see any galvanizing
force outside of his government that has
the capability to do something against
him the other thing you need to
understand is is that kosovo is an
emotional issue for the serb population
is very very high
some polling that usia has done
indicates that 80 percent of the serb
population believes kosovo should be
held on to at all cost he will play on
those traditional nationalist sentiments
in that regard unless he's faced with
other consequences that that he must
judge in the context of a deteriorating
economy and while the people he's
dismissed have not galvanized themselves
into another force he has to wonder
about what that'll all mean in the
context of the act and the threat he if
he faces against nato holding on to
kosovo include denial of any autonomy to
kosovo does that well independence is
what the serbs have opposed adamantly i
don't have any
precise handling on autonomy
but it's independence that they
absolutely oppose now this is this is
therein lies the rub
uh because the uck and the kla in in in
essence has held out for independence so
in between the autonomy and independence
we would hope some political solution
could be fashioned to meet both
objectives
thank you very much senator sessions
thank you mr chairman
i have been somewhat
taken aback by the
reports that i've read in newspapers
that indicate we may be on the verge of
committing one-third of 30 000 troops
necessary to secure kosovo i feel like
that's a matter of national commitment
that the congress has to be involved in
and the failure to do so would be a
failure of our responsibility so i
would
particularly was interested in your
comments director tenet and your written
remarks that throughout the region
political economic and social progress
is unsustainable without direct
international involvement in virtually
every aspect of policy formulation and
resource allocation the magnitude of
that long-term um implications of that
statement concern me and are i think
important to policymakers in the
congress recent news articles talked
about forty to fifty thousand troops
uh we've seen nine thousand eight
thousand figure floated two to five
thousand troops floated based on your
intelligence assessment uh is this kind
of united states commitment necessary to
achieve the goals that we would like to
achieve in kosovo well senator first let
me say you'll have the secretary of
defense and the policy makers in front
of you to sort of talk about their
thinking general hughes and i are the
wrong people to talk about what the size
of an american contribution should be
i would say to you that i think general
hughes and i would say that a ground
force a nato ground force is
indispensable to a solution how the
united states participates in what
manner it participates you'll be i'm
sure that the administration will be
talking to this committee and other
members of congress
as time wears on i'm sure they'll be
doing that this week they've already
begun consulting i believe
well it's a
matter that
i think we need to be talking with
nobody's talked to me about it i may
have talked to some other members of
congress um it it does seem that um
there is a real danger here
this is a
east west all kinds of historical
implications of importance but it's also
the balkans are also known as the
european back door it's their backyard
is it possible
or would you comment on whether or not
we would normally expect the europeans
under these circumstances to contribute
more than two-thirds of nato policies
have
normally
contemplated senator i don't want to be
evasive but i'm not involved in any of
those discussions i think the secretary
will be
more than more than willing and able to
discuss that with you i just have
you know no no no affiliation with any
of those discussions senator if i might
just interject i've had the opportunity
to consult with the secretary of defense
and the secretary of state
on a number of occasions in the past two
weeks it had been my hope this morning
to include as a
opening in is hearing
representatives from the department of
state and defense to address the policy
questions which are very important that
you've asked
they respectfully requested that i defer
that
for a day or two
but i assure you this committee will
explore these policy considerations with
appropriate witnesses in within the next
few days
in consultation with my colleague here
from the
uh
you will you and i'll talk about how we
can structure those hearings so we will
have them
and i think the country the united
states has shown leadership has shown a
recognition of the need for
a ground element of u.s forces with a
nato and again it has to be in an
environment where there's some uh
measure of agreement
for some type of ceasefire structure
between all factions
senator rob
thank you mr chairman and i agree with
that uh assessment let me ask a couple
of quick questions that do go to the
intelligence
part of this equation
first of all with respect to
the
differences between the uck or kla as we
prefer to
refer to that uh organization uh here
and president rouge and some of his
forces we have been concerned for some
period of time that there was a
a pacifist element and anything but a
pacifist element in terms of the
breakdown between the two are the
differences in your judgment and if we
can't go into this an open session i'll
understand but there are differences
that we can talk about in public between
uh president and and those that are
loyal to him and the kla and any of the
leadership that we can identify
we should provide that answer in closed
session sir all right how about with
respect to the supplying
uh of the kla at this point uh is there
anything on that matter that you can go
into an open session no sir
okay let me ask you another question how
about
the uh
verifiers in osce
[Music]
there have been various reports
that this committee and others have
received uh that the 2000 number that
was supposed to be achieved i believe by
the end of january
uh has not been achieved we've talked a
little bit about their vulnerability
during this particular period because
you
describe
as best you can their
the
completeness of their deployment
and the vulnerability
that they
have at this point in terms of any
more assertive action by nato or the
united states
once again sir
not wishing to p appear or be evasive
but
the osce of course is uh treated by us
as a friendly organization
and in the context of actions in kosovo
we do not know
in an intelligence context what it is
they're doing or not doing i think i can
generally agree with you that they have
not reached the 2 000 person limit they
set
for this period of time they haven't yet
achieved that presence in kosovo very
carefully in that environment it's in
nobody's interest to have them exhaust
themselves and and see brutality and the
kinds of killings that we think will
only only accelerate as time goes on
with the kind of instability that it
will perpetuate in the region but if we
were going to compare apples to apples
in a similar time period you must be
concerned about this environment because
people people have a lot of arms and
there's a real threat out there and
we'll have to be very careful which is
which is why i came back to my original
point that a political settlement is an
absolute or the preconditions of a
political settlement is an absolute
imperative to the introduction of forces
on the ground understood and i i
appreciate that point and i'll general
hughes did you want to come in just make
one point the geography alone
of kosovo if you examine the map
it tells you that you have a much
different operating environment
no access to the sea
as one example
and therefore conditions in kosovo must
be viewed differently from those that we
encountered in bosnia i was hoping to
elicit that general response at least so
that we recognize that the situation on
the ground that we can front is entirely
different my time has expired i thank
you mr chairman thank you abraham
thanks uh mr chairman thanks director
tenant and
general hughes
uh
i was thinking as we were talking about
this
of the
well let me first
thank
senator warner for the statements
he's been making on this difficult
subject which
i
think have been very much in the
national interest and a point that he's
made that i think is
important to stress is that
we've made an investment a substantial
investment in peacekeeping
arriving at peace and then keeping it in
bosnia
and uh to
some sense we ought to
be involved as much as we are and maybe
in the coming months in kosovo to
protect the investment we've made in
stability in the balkans as a way of
saying
expressing what i believe is true which
is that
stability in the balkans is important
stability in europe is important to
the security of the united states
and for one i feel strongly that if if
the efforts to bring the parties to
france are successful and they can agree
on terms and it's in our national
interest to be with our allies at nato
in a peacekeeping force
although i mean i must say i'm
encouraged to hear that the talk is that
the proportion of american troops will
be lower than it was at the outset in
bosnia and if one of the conditions of
that
is for the europeans to assume more
responsibility and including command of
those troops
i think we have to be prepared to accept
that but i wanted to ask a different
kind of question which was
if i can phrase it this way history
has put an awful lot of
diplomatic political
uh kindling wood in the balkans
but
it takes somebody to light the match and
i think as we we look at the recent
history there it's it's mr milosevic
who's lit the match
i did it in bosnia and he did it here in
kosovo ten years ago when uh under his
leadership the
uh
autonomy of the province was uh
nullified
and what has followed is a
systematic campaign which didn't come to
real public attention until
recent uh
times where the
ethnic identity the political rights the
civil rights of the kosovar albanians
has been
destroyed
and my question is
in a way i'm trying to
ask you director tenant to go back and
tell us a little more if you're able
then
same similar question what senator levin
raised
you know leadership can be bad
leadership and good leadership i think
melissa which leadership has been
terrible for the balkans and the in the
region and the question is what is the
hope of
of
one either new leadership different
leadership in belgrade or two
of imposing as part of a peace
settlement for kosovo's son
is
okay
yes
amazing
now
just
we'd be prepared to hear your opening
statements
thank you mr chairman we've got uh a lot
to say about excuse me uh the second the
director of ms snow just arrived would
you like
a minute before we start okay please go
ahead thank you mr chairman we'll try
and get through a a lot of things here
as fast as we can
in my opening i i would i would say to
you mr chairman that u.s citizens and
interests
are threatened in many arenas across a
wide spectrum of issues and no more no
issues more emblematic of these new
challenges than the proliferation of
weapons of mass destruction
as you know 1998 saw the nuclear test in
south asia continue concern about iraq's
weapons of mass destruction programs
accelerated missile development in iran
north korea pakistan and india and the
broader availability of bw and cw
relevant technologies
particularly worrisome to the
intelligence community is the security
of russian wmd materials
increased cooperation among rogue states
and more effective efforts by
proliferance to conceal illicit
activities
u.s intelligence is increasing its
emphasis and resources on many of these
issues but i must tell you that there is
a continued and growing risk of surprise
looking at the supply side first
russia and chinese assistance to
proliferate countries has merited
particular attention for several years
this year unfortunately is no exception
i mentioned in my statement last year
that russia had just announced new
controls on transfers of missile related
technology
there were some positive signs in
russia's performance early last year but
unfortunately there is not there has not
been sustained improvement
especially during the last six months
expertise and material from russia has
continued to assist the iranian missile
effort in areas ranging from training to
testing to components
this assistance is continuing as we
speak and there is no doubt that it will
play a crucial role in iran's ability to
develop more sophisticated and
longer-range missiles
making matters worse societal and
economic stress in russia seems likely
to grow
raising even more concerns about the
security of nuclear weapons and fissile
material
although we have not had recent reports
of weapons-usable nuclear material
missing in russia what we have noticed
are reports of strikes
lacks discipline and poor morale and
criminal activity at nuclear facilities
for me mr chairman these are alarm bells
that warrant our closest attention and
concern
the china story is a mixed picture mr
chairman
china's senior leaders are actively
studying membership in the missile
technology control regime
and have pledged to prevent the export
of materials or technology that could
assist missile and nuclear programs in
south asia
beijing has promulgated controls on dual
use nuclear technology and tightened
chemical export controls
we cannot yet assure you however that
the new export control mechanisms will
be effective
both the chinese government and chinese
firms have long-standing and deep
relations with proliferate countries and
we are not convinced that china's
companies fully share the commitments
undertaken by senior chinese leaders
while all aspects of china's
proliferation behavior bear continued
watching we see more signs of progress
on nuclear matters than on missile
assistance
moreover the restructuring of china's
defense industrial bureaucracy including
entities charged with export oversight
holds the potential to create confusion
and incentives that would impede the
effectiveness of this system
in short mr chairman our guard remains
up on this question
there is little positive i can say mr
chairman about north korea
the third major global proliferator
whose incentive to engage in such
behavior increases as it is as its
economy continues to decline
missiles and wmd know-how are north
korean products for which there is a
very real market
north korea's sales of such products
over the years have dramatically
heightened the wmd threat in countries
of key concern such as iran and pakistan
meanwhile countries such as india
pakistan and iran that traditionally
have been seen as technology customers
have now developed capabilities that
they could export to others
looking at the demand side mr chairman
let's focus first on nuclear programs
last spring dramatically made clear that
both india and pakistan are well
positioned to build significant nuclear
arsenals
meanwhile iran too
seems to be pushing its program forward
with regard to north korea the agreed
framework has frozen pyongyang's ability
to produce additional plutonium at
yongbyon
but we are deeply concerned that north
korea has a covert program
the t the key target for us to watch is
the underground construction project at
kumchang knee which is large enough to
house a plutonium production facility
and perhaps a reprocessing plant as well
the missile story is no more encouraging
indeed we expect the high level of
launch activity in 1998 to continue in
1999.
last year's activity included the first
launches of the north korean tapadong
one the pakistani gory and the iranian
shahab 3
the latter two based on north korea's
nodong
with a range of 1300 kilometers the
nodong shahab 3 and gory significantly
alter the military equations in their
respective regions
each is probably capable of delivering
weapons of mass destruction
in short mr chairman theater range
missiles with increasing range pose an
immediate and growing threat to u.s
interests military forces and allies and
the threat is increasing this threat is
here and now
more disturbing mr chairman is that
foreign missiles of increased range and
military potential are under development
north korea's three-stage tapadong one
launched last august demonstrated
technology
that with resolution of some very
important technical issues would give
north korea the ability to deliver a
very small payload to intercontinental
ranges including parts of the united
states although not very accurately
pyongyang is also working on another
missile the tapadong ii
with two stages the tapidong ii which
has not yet been flight tested would be
able to deliver significantly larger
payloads to mainland alaska and the
hawaiian islands and smaller payloads to
other parts of the united states
in other words the lighter the payload
the greater the range
with the third stage like the one
demonstrated last august on the tapadong
one this missile would be able to
deliver large payloads to the rest of
the united states
the proliferation implications of these
missiles are obviously significant
foreign assistance is a fundamental
factor behind the growth of the missile
threat
for example the foreign assistance
helped iran save years in its
development of the shahab 3 missile
which is based on the north korean
nodong and as i noted earlier include
substantial russian assistance
moreover iran will continue to seek
longer-range missiles and seek foreign
assistance in their development
if iran follows a development timeline
similar to that demonstrated with the
shahab 3 which included significant
foreign assistance it would take iran
many years to develop a nine thousand to
ten thousand kilometer range icbm
capable of reaching the united states
but iran could significantly shorten the
acquisition time and warning time by
purchasing key components or entire
systems for potential sellers such as
north korea
iraqi capabilities to develop missiles
also continues to be of concern iraq was
ahead of iran before the gulf war and if
sanctions were lifted we would have to
assume that iraq would seek longer-range
missiles
against the backdrop of an increasing
missile threat mr chairman the
proliferation of chemical and biological
weapons takes on more alarming
dimensions
at least 16 states including those with
missile programs mentioned earlier
currently have active cw programs and
perhaps a dozen are pursuing offensive
bw programs and a number of those
programs are run by countries with a
history of sponsoring terrorism
on terrorism mr chairman i must be very
frank with the committee in saying that
americans are increasingly the favorite
targets
u.s citizens and facilities suffered
more than 35 percent of the total number
of international terrorist attacks in
1998. this is up from 30 percent 1997
and 25 percent 1996.
looking out over the next year mr
chairman let me mention two very
specific concerns
first there is not the slightest doubt
that usama bin laden his worldwide
allies and his sympathizers are planning
further attacks against us
despite progress against his networks
bin laden's organization has contacts
virtually worldwide including in the
united states and he has stated
unequivocally that all americans are
targets
bin laden's overreaching aim is to get
the united states out of the persian
gulf but he will strike wherever in the
world he thinks we are vulnerable we are
anticipating bombing attempts with
conventional explosives but his
operatives are also capable of
kidnappings and assassinations
we have noted recent activities similar
to what occurred prior to the african
embassy bombings mr chairman and i must
to tell you that we are concerned that
one or more of bin laden's attacks could
occur at any time
and on that point mr tenet the
administration recently announced a
program
for the
threats here in holman the domestic usa
this committee will be looking into the
recommendations which i hope will be
forthcoming from the administration
i presume that
you and your department worked on the
formulation of that very important
initiative by the administration that's
what we had input into it and when you
say strikes those strikes could be at
home as well as abroad yes sir
one of my greatest concerns mr chairman
is the serious prospect that bin laden
or another terrorist might use chemical
or biological weapons bin laden's
organization is just one of a dozen
terrorist groups that have expressed an
interest in or have sought chemical
biological radiological or nuclear
agents
bin laden for example has called on the
acquisition of these weapons as quote a
religious duty and noted that quote how
we use them is up to us
earlier i referred to state sponsorship
of terrorism so let me take this
opportunity to say with respect to iran
that we have yet to see any significant
reduction in iran's support for
terrorism president hadamy took office
in august of 1997 but hardliners such as
the supreme leader continue to view
terrorism as a legitimate tool of
iranian policy and they still control
the institutions that can implement it
mr chairman my statement goes in at
length about counter-narcotics and
organized crime which is important the
threat of the y2k problem which is also
important but i want to move on to some
other areas if that's i think we should
for a moment though
talk about your assessment of the
progress or the lack thereof
that we're making in
the narcotics well sir think we've got a
very heavy commitment of
u.s resources and indeed u.s military
sausage general just give us a sort of a
summary on that uh
the threat remains significant despite
many successes particularly in the fight
against cocaine mr chairman the holistic
narcotics trade adapts quickly to law
enforcement pressures new markets and
shifting supply patterns but three
particular developments concern me
first there's good news and bad news on
coca cultivation in peru which has
historically accounted for more than
half of the andean total cultivation has
declined by more than half over the past
three years
cultivation in bolivia historically the
second largest coker producer has also
dropped substantially the bad news
however is that these declines are
largely offset by significant increases
in coca cultivation and production in
colombia
much of which is in high high risk
insurgent insurgent-controlled territory
making colombia's eradication efforts
more difficult
to president pastrana's credit and he is
waging a very serious fight with us
he is trying to engage the insurgents in
talks intended partly to seek their help
in eradication efforts the first time a
colombian president has taken such a
bold and risky step
second mr chairman
drug shipments are increasing overland
through central america to mexico and
from there across the southwest border
into the united states
finally mr chairman opium production the
source of all refined heroin has
ballooned in afghanistan this country
now accounts for almost 40 percent of
the potential worldwide opium production
and may be approaching burma as the top
heroin exporter in the world
it's a very difficult and moving picture
mr chairman every every time you make
progress you lose yardage someplace else
and there is no
there's no shortage of effort on our
part of the law enforcement's community
part to break the hold of these cartels
and their trafficking networks but it's
a tough problem
with regard to the y2k problem mr
chairman i think a two a few words are
in order
in our judgment foreign countries
translate on the ability of nations now
to technologically intercept our systems
whether it's the local bank or indeed
the department of defense
it's a serious issue mr chairman we
should talk about in closed session more
than an open session
in our judgment with regard to y2k
foreign countries trail the united
states in addressing y2k problems by at
least several months and in many cases
much longer
the lowest level of y2k preparedness is
evident in eastern europe russia latin
america the middle east africa and
several asian countries including china
why y2k remediation is underfunded in
most countries
these uneven efforts account for several
potential threats to our interests
global linkages to telecommunications
financial systems air transportation
manufacturing supply chain oil supplies
and trade mean that y2k problems will
not be isolated to individual countries
and no country will be immune from
failures in these sectors
there is a potential for civil unrest in
some countries particularly if critical
service sectors are disrupted for
extended periods
energy flows could be interrupted in
some countries europe for example gets
more than one third of its natural gas
from russia and could be affected if
gasprom has y2k problems some military
activities include those of our allies
depend on secure and uninterrupted flow
of digital information making overall
readiness a potential casualty of y2k
mr chairman i want to talk a bit about
russia and china to you let me start
with russia
last year i reported to you that my view
that russia's future direction whether
it develops as a stable democracy
reverts to autocratic and expansion
expansionist impulses of its past or
degenerates instability remained an open
question
my concerns about russia's direction are
greater today than they were a year ago
largely because russia's deteriorating
economy elevates the uncertainty
quotient in a number of very important
areas
just one year ago russia had its
problems but it had a basic sense of
direction and seemed to be moving
forward however fitfully
now however prime minister primakov is
struggling with mammoth problems
to his credit he has built a good
relationship with the legislature and
gained passage of some long overdue
legislation
but the nation is heading into a
political transition
facing difficult economic choices and
possibly entering a period in which it
debates its future political direction
this is playing out against continuing
instances of lawlessness and a growing
public sentiment for a stronger hand at
the helm
this could be a dangerous path for a
country with russia's authoritarian
history even though russia has now held
successful elections and adopted a
constitution
the sense of drift is accentuated by the
focus most political leaders already
have on the december 1999 duma elections
in the june 2000 presidential election
very few are disposed to take bold steps
or new initiatives that might risk
additional public pain right now
meanwhile president yeltsin's health
problem limit his involvement in
decision-making and place on prime
minister primakov much of the
responsibility for the day-to-day
management of the country
as the government ponders how to proceed
the economic indicators grow more
worrisome russian consumers have been
hit hard by inflation
prices have shot up 90 percent since
last since july
imports of consumer goods have now
fallen sharply unemployment has inched
up to nearly 12 percent and is spreading
to the emerging middle class class and
the economy will probably contract by
six to eight percent this year
this changed political dynamic and
economic slide highlights the foundation
of my increased concern
politically russia is increasingly
unpredictable and the worsening economic
situation affects all aspects of the
russian scene as the desperate search
for revenue streams is exacerbating a
number of very serious problems for
example it has magnified the
proliferation threat across the board as
growing financial pressures raise
incentives to transfer sensitive
technologies especially to iran
with regard to china mr chairman
my concerns bear some resemblance to
those about russia but in china's case
the trajectory is clearly different
china is a great power on the rise
diplomatically militarily and
economically there is no doubt that
china has the potential to affect our
security posture in asia but the extent
to which its ambitions and growing
capabilities represent a challenge or
threat to u.s interests is still an open
question
the chinese have signaled in summit
meetings and elsewhere that they want
constructive bilateral relations but at
the same time they remain fundamentally
suspicious of u.s intentions toward
china and like russia seek to constrain
any increase in u.s global influence
meanwhile china's military modernization
program continues the pace despite
slowing economic growth the chinese
program is assisted by sustained levels
of defense spending and the availability
of weapons and technologies from the
former soviet bloc
its focus is on air naval and strategic
nuclear modernization
china is increasing the size and
survivability of its retaliatory nuclear
force even though it is unlikely to make
the resource commitment needed to
approach the force levels either of the
united states or russia
china is also developing and acquiring
air and naval systems intended to deter
the united states from involvement in
taiwan
and to extend china's fighting
capability beyond its coastline
although china does not want a conflict
over taiwan it refuses to renounce the
use of force as an option and continues
to place its best new military equipment
opposite the island
china's future is also uncertain because
of its pressing domestic challenges on
the economic side china's major concern
this year will be sustaining economic
growth which officially reached almost
eight percent last year
china has not been immune from the
global financial crisis and much slower
growth this year would threaten labor
peace and increase pressure to devalue
the currency
a step that would fuel a new round of
financial turmoil in asia
these economic uncertainties have
heightened china's fear of civil strife
and the recent arrests of several
pro-democracy dissidents leave no doubt
that communist that china's leaders are
determined to sustain the communist
party's monopoly on political power
mr chairman i go on about iraq which we
can talk about but i'd like to talk
about more north korea more specifically
dangerous as saddam is mr chairman i can
hardly overstate my concern about north
korea in nearly all respects the
situation there has become more volatile
and unpredictable the regime is still
struggling with serious food shortages
last year's grain harvest having been
more than one million tons short of the
minimum grain needs
very few heavy industrial plants are in
operation living conditions for most
north koreans are miserable
incredibly this misery coexists with the
robust weapons of mass destruction
program i mentioned a few minutes ago
fresh signs of social decay have
increased our concern about stability in
north korea
crime and in discipline are commonplace
even in the military and security
services
citizens from all walks of life
including members of elite groups are
more apt to blame kim jong-il for
systemic problems including poor living
conditions
all of this will encourage the north to
rely still more heavily on risky
brinkmanship in its dealing with the
united states
pyongyang has a history of precipitating
crises that it thought it could control
to increase u.s engagement in bilateral
issues
a key area with this will play out in
the coming year is u.s efforts to
inspect the underground construction
project at kumchang ni which may be
intended to house a nuclear facility
the key point mr chairman is that north
korea remains a serious military threat
despite dire economic conditions in
addition to the wmd capabilities i
mentioned earlier pyongyang continues to
devote considerable resources to its
mainline military which can still
initiate full-scale war on the peninsula
and inflict massive damage on south
korea and the 37 000 american troops
deployed there
finally mr chairman i want to talk about
iran for a few moments
last year i described iran as a still a
dangerous state in which some positive
changes were taking place
changes that i could and stress could
lead to a less confrontational stance
with the united states iran has had a
tumultuous year and my sense is that it
is more likely to face serious unrest in
1999 than at any time since the
revolution 20 years ago
the situation is very fluid and the more
moderate elements represented by iran's
president harami are on the defensive to
a greater degree than ever before in
their struggle with the country's
conservatives
some of president hatami's domestic
reforms have come under intense attack
by conservatives and the current jump in
political violence including the recent
murders of several dissidents
suggests that some conservative elements
have decided to revert to force to
impose their will
hotomy now has an opportunity to use the
investigation into these murders in
which hardline elements appear
implicated to put his opponents on the
defensive
he needs to regain the momentum he
demonstrated in his first few months to
make concrete gains against
conservatives he could do so by using
the investigation to push for change
into the mois his intelligence service
and
combined with a large turnout in
nationwide elections later this month
could reaffirm his popular mandate to
push for reform
but his efforts will play out against a
background of severe economic stress in
iran
largely the result of the slump in
global oil prices this is making it
harder for kodamy to deliver on his
reform promises with high unemployment
also contributing to the potential for
civil unrest in the country
finally mr chairman we need to spare one
thing very soberly in mind that
reformists and conservatives agree on at
least one thing
weapons of mass destruction are a
necessary component and and therefore
get a high degree of priority thus as i
stated earlier we need to be vigilant
against the possibility of proliferation
surprise i'll stop there mr chairman
there's more to say but i've taken too
much of your time no we've taken
too little in many respects and we'll
turn to you momentarily general
but as i look back
direct lieutenant you and i have been
associated now for almost a decade
beginning with our work on the
intelligence committee when the demise
of the soviet union
and later i became the the deputy
of the joint chairman on that committee
so we've shared a lot
just give me your overview
of when we worked together ten years ago
in terms of the overall threats against
the united states
at the close of the cold war and in
comparison to what you feel the
magnitude of those threats are today
well in a sense i think mr chairman we
see the past and the future colliding at
the same time the difference here is is
the enormous implications of the flow of
technology to many more countries
while the homeland of the united states
may not be as threatened as it once
wanted because of a massive soviet
arsenal
i would say to you that american
interests are being pushed all over the
world in a way that i think is quite
unprecedented small actors with access
to technology organized criminals
terrorists narco traffickers
and the fact that that there are no more
there are no more unsophisticated
adversaries everybody has sophisticated
communication people know how to deceive
and deny information
alliances are very very fluid in many
ways the cause for engagement the cause
for a robust intelligence capability or
a robust diplomatic and military
capability have never been greater than
they are today
and the world we're looking at i think
will pose for our children challenges
that we have not yet conceived and
technology will be at the root of it all
and the proliferation of these weapons
i believe will be the single greatest
threat because this proliferation
intersects with terrorists it intersects
with organized crime in a way that
nation-states will be very well find it
very difficult to combat
so i think that's the kind of world
we're looking toward a world that is far
less predictable than we once thought
where our leadership is still required
where our resources are strapped and
when we need to do more to protect
american interests
i thank you and if we're looking here 10
years from today it'll even be more
complex i think it will sir
general hughes
mr chairman members of the committee i'm
pleased to once again have the
opportunity to provide my views
on the global threats and challenges
confronting our nation over the next two
decades
my remarks today touch on more detailed
testimony which i provided for the
record
as we have witnessed during the past
year
with the continuing proliferation of
weapons of mass destruction
highlighted by the nuclear detonations
in india and pakistan
heightened tensions along the line of
control in kashmir
disorder in indonesia
terrorist bombings of our embassies in
kenya and tanzania
north korean and iranian progress in
developing longer-range missiles
intense ethnic conflict
particularly in the balkans and central
africa
international and internal uncertainty
and economic crisis in russia
the devastating impact of hurricane
mitch in central america
narcotics trafficking and its corrosive
effects on governance in colombia and
surrounding countries
iraq's continued belligerence
and growing concern about the direction
north korea is taking
all of that
tells us that the international security
environment
remains volatile complex and very
difficult
i expect this general global turmoil to
continue and perhaps worsen
at least through the next decade
because the underlying causes political
economic social technological and
demographic
remain largely in place
we should therefore anticipate
a very dynamic environment in which
threats
challenges and opportunities
coexist intertwine and evolve
seemingly at random
i am particularly concerned
that the simultaneous occurrence of many
lesser crises
will result in a net effect
that could diffuse our focus
dissipate our power and resources
cause us to be reactive
and ultimately undermine our ability to
shape the future
against this backdrop of change i see
several themes
that i will that will define the nature
of the military threats and challenges
we are likely to encounter
over the next 10 years
no global military challenger on the
scale
of the former soviet union is likely to
emerge
however
the u.s will continue to be confronted
with a host of lesser dangers
regional transnational asymmetric and
asynchronous
these include increased numbers of
people in need
the continued existence of various rogue
renegade and outlaw individuals
sub-national groups and states
terrorism drug trafficking and other
transnational crime
the malevolent use of technology and
attendant proliferation
the rise of alliances and coalition with
opposing interests
and numerous other critical
uncertainties
collectively these and other challenges
represent a formidable barrier to the
emergence of a stable secure and
prosperous international order and a
substantial impediment to our strategic
vision
they will continue to absorb a great
deal of the us military's time energy
and resources
at the higher end of the spectrum the
united states will continue to face a
strategic nuclear threat from russia
china
and perhaps other less dependable
nations
indeed the proliferation of weapons of
mass destruction technologies and
missiles
constitutes the single greatest threat
to u.s vital national interests
the number of russian strategic nuclear
warheads will continue to decline
but moscow will retain a potent
strategic arsenal
and will increasingly rely on strategic
forces to offset its diminished
conventional military capability
china will modernize and expand its
relatively small and dated strategic
deterrent force
and the number of chinese warheads
capable of hitting the united states
will increase
though less certain i am very concerned
that adversaries like north korea and
iran
will develop and field
nuclear armed missiles with
intercontinental range
this more diverse and complex strategic
nuclear threat
affects post-cold war thinking about
nuclear deterrence
strike and response policy force posture
and strategic targeting
the threat posed by regional weapons of
mass destruction already the greatest
threat to deployed u.s forces worldwide
will increase
over the next 10 years several states
will likely join the nuclear club
chemical and biological weapons will be
widely proliferated
and the numbers of medium-range theater
ballistic and cruise missiles
will increase significantly particularly
in the middle east
this dynamic has the potential to
fundamentally alter theater force
balances
the nature of regional conflict and u.s
contingency planning and execution
we also can expect key regional powers
china and perhaps russia at the high end
but also an unimpeded iraq
iran
india
pakistan and north korea
to field conventional military forces
that are large and well equipped even by
today's standards
the degree to which these primarily
industrial age forces can acquire and
apply
selected high-end capabilities
weapons of mass destruction missiles
satellite reconnaissance global
positioning precision strike
advanced radar and so forth
remain to be seen but under certain
conditions
hybrid militaries combining the quantity
mass and firepower of 20th century force
with selected 21st century technologies
and concepts
will pose a significant threat to u.s
mission success
particularly in the period beyond 2010.
finally the emergence of a new
multi-polar threat paradigm and related
changes in the nature of warfare itself
underpin
all of the foregoing trends and are
having a profound impact
on u.s military missions
strategy organization
planning
operations and forced development
it is difficult to predict how these
trends will play out over the next two
decades
that uncertainty creates an extremely
challenging planning environment
for u.s policy makers and force planners
one of the most important challenges
facing the u.s intelligence community is
to discern from the general global
condition
a more specific characterization of
emerging threats
this characterization must be detailed
and timely enough
for our political and military leaders
to prevent
deter or prepare for those threats
before they become reality
and to fight and win against our enemies
if that becomes necessary
we in the defense intelligence community
remain committed to providing
the best possible military intelligence
support
to our leaders and in support of the
soldiers sailors airmen marines coast
guardsmen and civilian members of our
military
one final thought
we live and work in an era where access
to information is ubiquitous
and where public media coverage of
military operations is more pervasive
and aggressive than ever before
these conditions have combined to
challenge our traditional concepts of
operational
security and secrecy
in many instances
the provision of military information to
the public domain is expected
in some cases information is published
without official approval or clearance
this condition has both positive and
negative effect
much more information is now available
to the public
but some information endangers military
plans and intentions
and puts military operations and
personnel at risk
the overall result has been the
compromise of intelligence and
operational data
obtained at great cost to the american
taxpayer
in the public domain and coincidentally
to our enemies and adversaries
in some cases we have lost the element
of surprise
we have lost the initiative
and we have endangered or lost sources
of information
that are important windows into what our
opponents are doing
i do not have a clear solution to
recommend
but feel it is my duty as a military
officer who is entrusted to secure such
information
to bring this to your attention as a
matter of great concern
mr chairman that concludes my statement
thank you very much thank you very much
general we'll proceed now to around the
questions of six minutes for each
senator
[Music]
i want to return to the
situation in kosovo
again i think the administration
together with our allies are doing the
best but they can to bring the parties
together
now there's to be a meeting somewhere in
france
of the principles of all sides to what
extent is that coming together
and most particularly
are we able to identify the leaders in
the albanian
contingent to this meeting
mr chairman my understanding is is that
mr rugeville one of the albanian leaders
has
indicated a positive and positive i've
met with him i'm sure you have also and
milosevic has indicated he's still
studying the issue
the uck or the kla is
thinking about what its position will be
i have no i have nothing more definitive
this morning there may be of course you
know rugeva represents the more moderate
uh
factions within the albanian
population
what about the more should we say the
ones
allied with the kla uh they have yet to
take a position on whether they're going
to show up on associations yes sir
general do you have anything further
down
that's uh correct answers
uh
much discussion of recent and this
committee had a very good hearing the
other day on iraq
and trying to get an appraisal of the
factions outside of iraq and their
ability to be
partners so to speak in
the new goal of regime
change
what comments can you give us about your
own appraisal of the outside factions
their viability
their willingness to accept assistance
financial and otherwise from the western
world
in a
combined effort by many parties to work
for a regime change
well mr chairman i don't think the
director of central intelligence should
talk about that in open session i'd be
happy to give you my very candid and
direct assessment of that in closing
when we when we go into
closed
of recent the administration and i
commend the secretary of defense for his
efforts
has come to the recognition about the
ballistic missile threat to the united
states
such that he is
including in the president's budget
submission which has now come to the
congress
certain components which begin to
clarify exactly the administration's
position
as it relates to this nation's
initiative to try and devise
a ballistic missile defense system
which in sharp contrast to the
concepts that we followed under the
reagan administration
is directed towards
those few missiles that could be
accidentally or intentionally released
by terrorists or other groups
what comments do you have on that and
the ability of this country hopefully to
renegotiate the the treaty
that is
critical
to allowing
the full potential of american
technology to be brought to bear
on this the abm treaty senator i'm not
competent to make judgments about what's
being pursued i think what general
hughes
and i tried to do in our statements
was be very careful about portraying
what we believe to be a growing threat
we said i said quite emphatically that
the theater threat is here and now
i talked about north korean developments
we in our report to you in this spring
and with the help of the rumsfeld
commission and new methodologies i think
we'll see a
we're looking at this problem because we
think we have to be very careful about
it but the flow of technology foreign
assistance
uh the application and transition from
space launch vehicles to icbms
there are lots of developments out there
that have forced us to rethink this
threat all we can say to you is is that
proliferation of this technology is a
very serious issue for us the policy
choices you make the technologies you
buy
the implications of what you do with the
abm treaty are serious policy matters
generally hughes and i will try and keep
the threat let me go back to your
statement you said certainly the theater
threat is here we saw that
during the gulf war well it's here
but the point is we now recognize the
growing capabilities of north korea that
brings in
not a theater but an intercontinental
threat yes sir so i think would your
response be to both theater and
intercontinental well the theater threat
is here and now with it with a diversity
that that is quite threatening the icbm
threat the north korean developments the
interaction among rogue states the very
active
actions that countries are seeking to
acquire long-range ballistic missiles
tell us that this is a threat that will
be increasingly more difficult to warn
against in the conventional timelines
that we once did and that's the kind of
message we want to leave you with
general hughes the president announced
as a part of his counter-terrorism
initiatives he's considering the
appointment of a single military
commander
as his anti-terrorism commander-in-chief
i don't have all the details but
initially i'm i'm inclined to support a
study of this concept
and see whether or not we can have a
meeting of the minds between the
administration and congress do you have
any comments on that
uh no i don't have any comments on that
sir
senator levin
thank you mr chairman um
first relative to kosovo i just want to
add one further thought
there i think is
some concern and some mixed feelings on
the question of u.s participation in a
ground force in kosovo even if there is
some kind of a interim peace agreement
i happen to be one who would favor our
participation for instance under the
right circumstances following such a
date and like agreement in kosovo
there are some who i think
would perhaps not support
such participation
but
two things are clear to me
one is that the europeans are finally
leading
and we ought to
be thankful that they are
and i think there's some
sometimes some ambivalence that is
directed towards europe in terms of
their leadership and i'm not talking
about ambivalence from youtube but
ambivalence that sometimes comes from
this country about whether or not
we want them to actually lead such a
force
if in fact one is put together by nato
and it seems to me if we want the
europeans finally to do more
in their own area which they should have
been doing all along we have got to be
positive and supportive
and grateful that they finally are
taking a leadership role i'm glad that
that conference on kosovo is being held
in france and not in the united states
that the symbolism of that
that it's in europe and not here it
seems to me as important symbolism i am
all for it i want the europeans to lead
i'm glad they are and if a nato force is
put together after some kind of an
interim dayton like agreement is reached
i would hope that we would participate
but that we would not
in any way suggest that we are reluctant
to have that nato leadership be european
nato leadership instead of us in terms
of the direct command of that force
so
i just want to
kind of add that one element to our
thinking on it that doesn't mean there's
agreement
on a lot of aspects of this policy i
don't think there are in terms of even
american participation in such a force
although i do support participation
of the united states in a
junior partner role in such a force with
a much smaller share than has previously
been the case
senator you still would have the supreme
allied commander general of course and
it would be the
another nation over the immediate force
that's why i said direct command
the um
now on the the threats that we face
you have given us a very eloquent
statement of the growing nature of
terrorist threats
particularly in possession of weapons of
mass destruction
we are facing we already do face a
theater missile threat and we are facing
a growing threat in terms of long-range
missiles we are seeing that
and there's much evidence of that and
you've identified some of that this
morning
it would be very helpful for us if you
could
assess the likelihood
of these various threats
being
actually used against
americans in american interest
actually being implemented
now you may or may not be able to do
that right now for us but it is very
important that we
get a flavor on a scale of one to ten is
it
an eight that a terrorist will poison a
water system with a chemical in the
united states compared to a two that
we're going to face a
missile
coming in from some rogue nation or is
that the opposite now
it's a difficult thing to do but it's a
very important thing for us to do you've
been extremely
i think very
impressive this morning in your
description of the growth of those
terrorist threats and that's where i
happen to feel the greatest real threats
lie
and although the missile long-distance
missile threat is a growing one in my
judgment
not as an expert in my judgment the
likelihood that we will face a terrorist
threat with a weapon of mass destruction
domestically is far greater than that
we're gonna get a missile coming in from
north korea although that is a growing
possibility for the record would you to
give us yes your
likelihood assessment relative to these
threats give us the range of threats and
the likelihoods that they would actually
we would actually
see one of those threats carried out and
implemented
the
next question relates to a testimony on
page 24 of your prepared
statement
and that
is that in north korea
we see
evidence of crime and in discipline in
the military and security services
is right in the middle of that page and
citizens from all walks of life in north
korea
including members of elite groups are
more apt to blame kim jong-il for the
problems including poor living
conditions and i think it's a very
significant statement that i hope we
don't overlook
like many of my colleagues i've been to
north korea and i've seen the total
totalitarian nature of that regime and
the small opportunity anybody would have
for any kind of dissent or a complaint
i'd be interested as to the source
not the source in your technical sense
but what do you base
that
statement on that and you've now made it
public that crime and indiscipline are
commonplace in the military and security
services in north korea and that
citizens
including members of elite groups are
more apt to blame their
leader for the systemic problems
we do have a variety of
information reports
coming from sources both classified and
official sources and from
travelers and people who are resident in
north korea who are able to observe
the ambient circumstances there which do
indicate to us this growing
instance or or circumstance where in
discipline is seen on the street
an example might be a soldiers out of
uniform and in disarray acting in a way
that was not seen before
another example might be public
marketplaces
in which governmental control over the
public commerce does not seem to be as
ubiquitous and as pervasive as it once
was
other examples from intelligence
reporting might indicate
some kind of indiscipline problem or
disruption in the normal course of a
military units activities
indicating a problem of command and
control inside the unit
and finally i think we have seen some
indications
throughout the country of distribution
problems
especially with food and other
resources which are in part
needed by the public which are denied
from the public by the government or by
the military or by some official concern
and that's another example of the kind
of problem we see where
people need things they can't get from a
government and so they
act out their frustrations and we get
reports about that thank you my time is
up i would just close with the request
just very briefly that
threat spectrum which we just discussed
and the likelihood of those threats
actually being faced here
would you be able do you think to give
us that within 30 days
yes thank you thank you
i think probably much of that would be
in classified form would it not leave
well
i'd like it in both classified online
classifieds well why don't we try and
classify it first
we'll do our best we'll do our best yeah
i think it'll be most valuable in
unclassified form if you can give it to
us in general terms in in unclassified
form but whatever you can give us in
unclassified be appreciated thank you
very much mr levin mr roberts you have
just joined us here you haven't had any
opportunities yet and you're the new
chairman of the
emerging threats subcommittee
here
comes uh thank you mr chairman that was
a very appropriate segue
i can't think of a
a better
stage setter if you will
for the work of the subcommittee and
what we're going to tackle this year and
i can assure
the distinguished uh
senator from michigan that
his question uh pretty well summarized
or his request is pretty well summarized
but we think the uh priority
consideration is in regards to the
subcommittee
this has been a very sobering look
at the threat environment that we face
in the united states
and i'm just going to read a couple of
paragraphs here for my opening statement
if i might mr chairman
the gravity of those threats and the
sheer number of possible scenarios that
could strike at our vital national
interest interest pardon me
certainly demonstrates the importance of
the understanding of the threats and to
prioritize them and that goes to the
heart
of senator levin's uh request and then
looking at our capabilities against them
so the challenge becomes one of
understanding which threat poses
the most serious danger to the nation
and then ensuring the various government
agencies are working together to reduce
the threat to
a minimum i would like to report to the
full committee and the chairman
we have already met with mr dick clark
of the national security council
and i was
i found it most helpful to determine
there are at least 13 federal agencies
involved
in this mission
and also general boyd the retired air
force general uh who is in charge of the
boren rudman commission uh made up of 30
national leaders
so we have enough task forces and
commissions and subcommittees and
committees
and your expertise to take a good hard
look at this and i will report to the
full committee we expect to hold a
hearing
later as of this month and a series of
about six hearings to do this kind of a
job
so with your help we'll be able to start
the process of pairing the list
if you uh if i can use that term now
both of you have listed many threats or
potential threats
and my question is how would you
prioritize those threats based on our
vital national interests now this is the
same thing that senator levin has asked
and i know you're going to provide
the full committee this information but
let me just give you
uh where i'm headed now george you
in your statement listed a great number
of threats and i uh found it very
interesting and the same thing is true
in regards to general hughes testimony
if you start off i don't know whether
you did this in regards to priority to
vital national interests but it was
interesting to me that the threat
of the weapons of mass destruction was
obviously first and the threat in the
balkans was number 10 out of 10.
now we
have
had a a great deal of conversation this
morning
and interest in regards to kosovo
and i know that
in that part of the world in the balkans
that our total expenditures over a
several year period are what 10 12 maybe
fourteen fifteen billion dollars
seven thousand troops to participate in
the uh twenty eight thousand that may be
involved
i don't know about our intelligence
capability there
or the climate there in regards to force
protection but it
it seems to me that that uh
particular issue is really dominating
uh not only the intelligence community
to a certain extent but uh certainly the
national news and certainly
certainly our commitment and i'm a
little concerned i know that our
peacekeeping responsibilities are very
serious there in the dayton accords and
what can happen in that area and the
future of nato
all of these things are important but
you've sort of rated it uh
you know 10 out of 10. am i being a
little bit uh
what unfair here or would you care to
comment yes
um i think that uh when we put this
together we initially were going to have
a an opening session devoted to kosovo
with policy witnesses that's going to
happen in another forum
so i must tell you that in putting this
together until midnight last night we
were trying to figure out how to address
it not necessarily in the sequence but
if i would characterize this for you
from an intelligence perspective it will
be
bosnia and kosovo will be at the top of
our surge efforts something we have an
immediate responsibility to put it our
highest priority but when you look at
iran and terrorism and proliferation
these are enduring threats where we get
no relief in our performance
things the country will face for the
next 10 or 15 years and where we surge
in in any two or three year cycle is
going to change over the course of time
so
i do look at them somewhat differently
but the immediacy whenever u s forces
are put on the ground it is my first
priority of necessity to ensure that the
force protection issues are paramount or
consideration so no man or woman in
uniform is jeopardizing the conduct of
their mission because of bad
intelligence that will be our number one
priority but when you ask me to do these
priorities i must tell you that i don't
have a lot of relief
the nuance between ballistic missile
terrorism narcotics what the iranians
the indians and pakistanis are capable
of is minute in terms of threat to vital
american interests these are areas that
i have to perform against with equal
with an equal degree of sophistication
because you would expect no less so
while in washington senator we often get
the cottage industry of the month and
everybody it's like the three-year-old
soccer game everybody runs to the ball
i don't have that luxury i have to treat
all of these things
equally and it's stressing in terms of
people and investment in resources
and so the divergence that whatever
delta exists here is very small because
when that next terrorist event occurs by
god the whole country will be up telling
me it's the most important threat and
the next time the north koreans flight
test a ballistic missile by god it'll be
the most important thing you missed mr
director if you missed it
so i have to make i treat these very
very closely and equally in my
priorities and kosovo will rise
immediately to get to your question and
i didn't mean to slide it in testimony
preparation but you know how those
things get at the 11th hour sometimes
i'm glad i asked that question so you
could get off your chest i i think i did
sir thanks sort of
[Laughter]
it was sort of a sensation
here
well obviously force protection is
numero uno uh where we have our
american men and women in uniform
and i i am concerned mr chairman uh i
think i'd echo the concern of senator
sessions i wasn't here but i understand
he said that you better have a
settlement first before we send anybody
in there
uh to keep the alleged peace
but i think we're spoon feeding this
settlement
and it's a lot like when i tried to
spoon feed my kids
and we're also
having a forced invitation
and i'm a little concerned about the
intelligence climate in regards to force
protection
down the road
if we would
if nato would make the decision
to go ahead and bomb
i'm not sure in the end result we don't
get the law of unintended effects and we
can we can deal that in regards to
closed session uh mr chairman my time
has expired
uh so i would like to come back uh with
an additional question down the road
senator sessions
thank you mr chairman
i'd like to ask a few brief questions
with regard to narcotics
i was involved as a federal prosecutor
on the gulf coast for a number of years
it strikes me
that what i've been what i hear now
about the potential to reduce the
production of coca and and other
products is the same thing i was hearing
in the early 1980s there's always some
positive report but fundamentally the
supply appears to be
there always to meet the demand within
the united states
would you have any comment that our best
way to
reduce the drug use in the united states
is to reduce demand in the united states
and isn't it basically a hopeless
game to attempt to reduce our drug use
by stopping nations from producing these
products well sir i think of course the
demand side is critical and
general hughes and i normally don't
comment on that but i will say to you
that i don't think it's hopeless
i think that you we make progress
against these organizations we not only
go after their crops we go after their
infrastructure their finances how they
transport things
and host nation support and will to do
those things has made a difference in
some places now it seems like a losing
battle on most days it is and the money
involved in the sophistication of these
organizations and often the unevenness
with which host governments attack the
problem
but we have our law enforcement and
intelligence communities i guess would
say we can't get off the playing field
because the consequence of getting off
that playing field and not trying to
make life as miserable as we can for
drug traffickers is not a situation i
think we'd want to be in but this is
tough business and the corruption piece
of it makes it a lot tougher and you
know that
and
there's no easy fix here and of course
if the demand side went away we'd be a
lot better off immediately well i think
you just
said correctly there's no easy fix uh
you get one if you drive the price up by
getting a lot of nations to reduce
supply the price will be so attractive
that others will get into it it's just a
i'm not sure we're going to be able to
solve our drug problem by blaming it on
colombia i've been at it a long time and
and
i'd rather see our focus on open-air
drug markets in united states cities and
and things of that nature um generally
senator i'd say that we wouldn't blame
it on and certainly i would say that the
pastrana government is trying to engage
us
every way they know how and doing some
courageous things i don't blame it on
any one government it's this is a
sophisticated multi you know
conglomerate business operation it
doesn't doesn't have any regard for the
sanctity of anybody's borders but
you know that well i agree with that and
um
colombian leaders have shown
extraordinary courage and many of them
are in the grave today because of it and
trying to resist this and none of us in
this nation have had to face that kind
of threat
general hughes uh with regard to your
concerns about
pub public
or
non-confidentiality and secrecy within
the united states how would you compare
our
problem with confidentiality and secrecy
with that of other democracies are we
more open and does it jeopardize our
intelligence community more than we
ought to and can we make some progress
in uh providing
our intelligence agencies more
confidentiality and protection
i don't think i'm qualified to make a
comparison with other democracies but i
would like to comment on the on the
problem or the issue as i see it we have
a set of laws
and rules and regulations
that are put in place to protect the
idea that some information should be
restricted from the public domain for
good reason
and that
is not uh being honored as far as i can
tell
u.s classified information
is routinely appearing in the public
media
and it's appearing in some cases
ahead of or in advance of events so that
it has a very deleterious effect
i'm concerned about that from the
standpoint of not only
operating forces and costs to them but
also to the
i don't know the confidence that we can
have in our system of protecting real
secrets
in our open society so this would be in
violation of existing law yes and
somehow my view is we have to find the
right balance i think we
may have had it at one time
but we seem now to have aired on the
side of making so much information
available that some of it has been
damaging to our
governmental collective effort
senator if i could just add to that i
think that i think that our government
is hemorrhaging in a way that i've never
seen in my lifetime and the implications
for the nation's security are profound
uh and i would tell you that unless
uh some discipline is restored in this
system openness is something we believe
in we're here today we want to talk to
the american people about what we
believe
but it is not anybody's inalienable
right to share secret information
and while people go after the people in
the press for printing things they're
not the problem the problem are the
people who believe they derive some
power from leaking classified
information and as a member of the
executive branch i will say that the
executive branch is probably responsible
for 80 of what appears
uh people just have lost their sense of
discipline and at the end of the day we
will lose our ability to serve you
because of that lack of discipline is
that the responsibility of the fbi
normally to investigate yes sir and and
the director director of the fbi and i
work very hard at this and it will only
take
one time to catch somebody uh to send
the right kind of message but it is a
very difficult problem for us we live
with it in the newspapers every day and
it makes my job and pat hughes's job
very difficult
very profound statement mr director
senator landrieu thank you mr chairman
thank you for the presentations this
morning both of you director in general
and just two questions
you outlined pretty clearly and
convincingly about the new emerging and
numerous threats that we face quite
different perhaps than the last 20 years
and
talked about the reasons for that
my question would be how does our
proposed budget
for your operations evil either enable
you
or prohibit you
from doing the kind of job that you feel
like you need to do
um senator i would say
that we're making progress in that
regard we had a very large infusion of
money last year from the congress that
was very very helpful to us
i would say as we come up and make our
budget submissions this year that we
have over the long term we have to sit
down and have a major look at how much
money the country is willing to spend on
intelligence there are glaring glaring
needs of the defense department and in
the intelligence community and at the
state department all the tools that the
president has available for national
security
i believe we need to carefully look at
whether we're spending enough
we can do what we've been asked to do
but the recapitalization requirements we
have the added investments we're trying
to make and and signals intelligence and
human intelligence and greater
analytical depth will require a
sustained commitment of resources to
ensure that i can deliver the
intelligence that you think we did the
country deserves over the course of time
and this is a debate that often occurs
in one year chunks that's one of my big
problems we talk about these things year
year year at a time
and i need to be able to talk about
significant programs over four and five
years to tell you that i can sustain a
level of investment that i think we need
i think we need to look at how we budget
and we need to think about what the
long-term needs are general hughes and i
will tell you that we can deliver what
we've been asked to do but we are under
more stress than we've ever been
as an intelligence community and we are
operating in an environment of massive
technological change that jeopardizes
our ability to do our job and our
investment profile has to be looked at
very very carefully and we do that we
are beginning to do that more carefully
and
so i think we we we've got a lot of work
to do here i'm not handing sticking my
hand out for money here today but as we
go forward in our budget deliberations i
would ask this committee who is
enormously sensitive to our needs to
look at the defense and intelligence
investments as synergistic as how we
help the defense department do its job
not as an either-or proposition and i
think too often we fall into that trap
mr chairman we take money away from the
defense department give it to the
intelligence community all the
constituents get very upset
that's not the way we look at it i view
the defense department's health and
welfare as primary to securing this
country but i think that we add an
enormous amount of value to what the
secretary and the chairman try to do
two words force multiplier yes sir
my second question is um general you
mentioned i believe um
the situation in central america and
honduras with um
hurricane mitch i've been down there to
visit there'll be other trips going down
and many of us are taking the
opportunity to go and see so that we can
help
you mentioned it do you have any
indication that the democracy that is
emerging there has been
negatively affected to a point where we
should be worried
and if so would you want to comment
because i know the damage has been quite
significant and there's a tremendous
amount of
suffering going on there
right now i would not i would say that
we have not detected a
political change in the region because
of the natural disaster
but rather we do need to assist those
countries in maintaining internal
stability
in rebuilding their infrastructure and
in
ensuring that conditions there are as
good as as we can help to make them so
that they can continue the
emerging democracy and change in
governance that you do see there i would
say that so far
out of that disaster my view is that the
governments in that region have handled
themselves very well
and that we should see great hope in
their
responsible
response to the people
of the region and to the conditions that
they they have to live through i do
think we need to keep our eye on on the
region and continue to assist in any way
that we can
thank you thank you mr chairman you'd
like to take another minute or two i'm
fine that's the only two i had senator
on behalf of this committee and indeed
the senate i wish to commend you for
your work and travels in connecting with
hurricane mitch
a great many members of the armed forces
u.s and other countries primarily u.s
are involved in that humanitarian relief
program
and it brings into sharper focus the
fact that
i think in
in considerable
measure the future will require more
participation by members of the u.s
armed forces
in these disasters
particularly when they occur in this
hemisphere
mr chairman it um
you know i think the statistic is
correct but
just to give
those that may not know when hurricane
andrew hit the united states it was a
0.04 percent
impact on our gnp in terms of the the
the amount of disaster that was you know
rendered by that blow
for honduras the estimate is 40
of their gnp which just puts into
perspective how huge
this storm in this national you know
natural disaster was even from louisiana
we've seen storms but this one was quite
extraordinary
and it hit a country that was just sort
of emerging and coming out and it could
really be a tremendous setback so i
appreciate the military's efforts to
look at it in our long-range interest
and to work with you mr chairman perhaps
there's some ways that we could think of
you know cost-effective ways that we can
help in these situations because it is
clearly in our interest for this region
to continue
its progress towards democracy in many
many ways and it's right in our back
door and their neighbors and friends and
so everything we can do we should try
one thing comes to mind senator and
you'd be very helpful in this is whether
or not we should institute some formal
training
in our various syllabus throughout from
boot camp up as to whether or not
we should focus on what a young service
person from this country good
opportunity for training and i think the
national guards have been using it in
that way and perhaps there are other
ways it could be of mutual benefit
for both
sides so i look forward to working with
you on that thank you senator um one
more question
and then i'll want to turn to you and
then i'll follow up thank you mr i just
had one question to follow up must
detent it on your remarks you've listed
a sobering
range of threats discrete individual
type threats the united states and what
i hear you saying is
that we need to strengthen our
intelligence community uh in some ways
more today because of that broad range
and
unconnected threats than maybe we were
in the past did i hear you say that well
you'll always hear me be an unabashed
advocate for doing just that sir i think
that what we
the range of places that we're asked to
operate the range of places where our
interests are at stake will demand
a higher quality intelligence than
you've ever expected in your lifetime
and the country has to be prepared to
understand that an investment is
required to make sure the united states
is ahead of the game and we've begun
that investment but i would ask that we
pay careful attention to how we sustain
it over the course of time to ensure
that we can deliver the information that
you and the president need to make these
judgments consistently there are others
out there who can who try to deny us
this information conceal it from us and
the kind of operational tempo that the
military intelligence communities have
undertaken in recent years
have us often focused on the here and
now when we have other longer term
requirements that we also have to pay
attention to so operational focus is
important and what you're doing in your
inbox today is important but the
strategic threats that the country faces
are equally important and it's my job to
balance that
this committee has always been very
helpful and very good to us in that
regard and i hope that when we have our
budget deliberations we can we can talk
about these issues at greater depth
thank you
we will do that
through the years i've taken a personal
interest in this committee
in our oversight responsibilities and
allocation of the most significant part
of the intelligent budget is under the
purview of the senate armed services
committee
i want to wrap up
in looking through my notes you covered
an awful lot of material mr director
but
i guess it was your little story about
the three years old at the soccer game
we tend to forget about iran
and the fact that iran is always in
direct competition with iraq
and
to some extent this stability in the
gulf region
is dependent on the coexistence of these
two states
and not allowing either to become
preeminent
we have that is the world been i think
discouraged by the ability of any
moderate voices to survive
for any particular time
there was a period here a year or so ago
where there was some indication there
was hope between the balance between
moderate and the more hardline voices
the moderates are rapidly disappearing
and then the weapons of mass destruction
they have been hell-bent
on their own programs for many years and
i wonder if you'd sort of give us a wrap
up on mr chairman i think you would be
uh at any point in time one side or the
other may appear to be winning i think
it would not be correct to say that this
has been decided inside iran i think you
have to remember that there was a very
large plebiscite
for
president for hotomy that reflects an
undercurrent of a desire for change
now at any moment in time one side or
the other may be winning i think the
thing that concerns me is while we watch
that we also have to be very cognizant
of the fact
that
there's been no change in
iranian-sponsored terrorism
and irrespective of whether the
moderation will change in other words at
the same very
high level causes us financially and
otherwise and at the same level at the
same time we need to understand as i
said in my statement that whether
moderates or conservatives win the the
power that derives from weapons of mass
destruction has been something the
iranians have sought going back to the
time of the shah their national interest
is served by this there may not be much
in the way of
change what we want and hope for is a
government that will integrate itself
into the into into our relationships
better and understand that the
confluence of weapons and mass
destruction and terrorist activities are
things that are really inimical not just
to the regional interest but to ours in
terms of moderating behavior either
towards those issues or the peace
process
these are very very serious issues so at
any moment in time this may shift i
think this is a story that will evolve
over the course of time and bears
watching on our part i don't think
there's much we can do about it or
should do about it i think these are
very serious internal issues but there
is something there in the plebiscite
that elected hotomy that cannot be
ignored
but then again to the weapons of mass
destruction program the level of effort
do you see any change no sir i think
this is very very serious on the missile
front on all fronts and we can talk
about it more in closed session but no
diminution and activity at those
with regard to those behavioral patterns
that concern us the most
have not fundamentally changed
general do you have any wish to add
no i i don't want to add anything to
what mr kennedy said but i'd like to
give him one view on iran
for some years now they have
deliberately and consistently
sought to acquire and perhaps even to
develop on their own
a military capability far in excess of
what they need for defensive purposes
and some of the goals they have some of
the weapons systems they seek clearly
have offensive implications
especially in their region i think we
have to view iran not only from a
defensive standpoint with regard to the
protection of their own people in their
own territory
but whether or not they can use the
weapons systems and the capabilities
they have now in our building
to interact with their near neighbors
and to become
more active in the region in military
terms
and
i once again i wish to characterize iran
as not an immediate
problem
but a long-term problem which has grown
over time and continues to grow
directly in our view and i'm not sure
what to tell you about that except that
we are alerting you
to this growing potential threat from
this country
thank you very much
the committee will now
recess for a period of 10 minutes and
return to a closed section in the
intelligence committee hearing room
[Music]
[Music]
so
okay
foreign
so
the best
oh
today the senate met for a pro forma